ATF explosive detection k9 Gavin has a
canine form of post-traumatic stress
disorder in nearly a month of the dog
psychology center Gavin has begun to
improve but Cesar still hasn't solved
the riddle behind this heroic dog's
unpredictable responses let's go as part
of the rehabilitation process Cesar
continues to bring Gavin to assist on a
variety of dog whisperer stories
[Music]
at Caesars home gavin performs well and
yet another ear-splitting challenged
eight-year-old Calvin Millan and his new
drum set good deep breath at this point
- thank you thank you okay so I'm gonna
go ahead and put some acupuncture
needles in
Gavin's rehabilitation also includes
regular acupuncture treatments which
help release the body's natural
feel-good neurotransmitters endorphins
reduce anxiety and generate deep
relaxation
[Music]
there she is our new member off the pack
and later on I will tell you why we need
a pregnant female for mr. Gavin when
Cesar and his staff learned about a
stray pregnant female they brought the
dog to the center hoping that the birth
of the puppies would help Gavin on a
path to regaining his instinctual side
hey that's good hey the pregnancy can
lead her into aggression no it's not a
very aggressive growling it could be
more from a protective point of view
she's a pregnant female surrounded by
all these guys the most important part
is Gavin Gavin to feel you know
attracted to the saying Gavin come here
come on buddy this is for you hey so
we're gonna give her a bath
this way the park will accept her
quicker because the scent we're gonna
neutralize the scent
on day 34 gavin continues his journey
toward becoming a balanced dog when a
dog in heat brings out a bit of Gavin's
primal sonic i love days like this right
so here we have a little dog that is a
coming in heat not a choice that we took
but we were rescued this dog and she's
in heat and so Gavin Gavin right now is
very excited perfect time to bring
anything that makes him afraid anything
in this case we have we have recorded
some sound perfect perfect time let's
hear it we want the excitement we want
him to believe the back see as you see
he got a little hesitant look at that
that's a battery actor come on buddy
let's go let's go back over here that's
a good boy see so you see the reaction
and then you wait for up there again
that would that's not what we want we
want him to go back into his old self
come on buddy come on
yeah we don't want him to go in hi
that's just a big note come on come on
just go back to your game
[Music]
this is good you know instead of him
running away from situation we actually
want him to come near us that's better
than just going and hide we don't want
the hide in this way I can influence him
you know so as you saw the sound totally
broke broke the concentration of the
nose which is actually unnatural the
nose should be more powerful than sound
always especially a female in heat just
the sound the guy you totally forgot
about the mating part of it what's wrong
with you
[Music]
steak Gavin
Caesar employs a system similar to
Gavin's ATF training using treats that
Gavin can find as a reward even when
they are near the source of the sound
[Music]
ah good boy hahaha good job
fantastic great